[Music]
l-3 at lap is really a matter of set
zero of particles and set zero particles
decay into everything we think is truly
elementary today with one exception
namely the top quark
let is the machine in Geneva Switzerland
which where 727 kilometers sircumference
has four interaction regions l-3 being
here where electrons and positrons
collide with energies up to 100 GeV
l-3 surrounds the intersection region
with the vertex chamber and a huge facet
I of 12000 crystals of bgo to detect
photons and electrons hadrons go into
the 400 tonnes of uranium calorimeter
and muons will penetrate everything and
be bent under the influence of the 0.5
Tesla field and registered and analysed
in distress chambers l3 also is a
collaboration of 500 scientists from 42
institutions led by Professor ting
technically all three is optimized for
precision in muons and photons and
electrons such that the resolution is 1%
in diamond mass and Delta P over P 2.5
percent since resolution goes linear
with B what's quadratic with L a very
large conventional magnet was
constructed the very good unique photon
resolution was achieved by new crystals
basement germinate
the magnet itself has 140 turns to
generate five killer gas-filled and that
necessitates a large coil with a hefty
wire carrying 30,000 amps the magnetic
field return is done by 8,000 tons of
iron making it the largest electromagnet
in the present moment according to The
Book of Records from Dennis
you see it here in the moment that the
support tube was cantilevered in which
carries all other components of the
detector the muon detector each of these
wheels is 95 tons gently glides on air
content so the alignment of 30 microns
is not upset here you see it in reality
and behind this is an alignment which
the moon's coming from the intersection
region are measured to 30 microns
accuracy and their Bend this was checked
and under battle conditions from set
decays where you know that the muon
should have the momentum of the beam and
indeed from almost 9,000 events now
observed a resolution of 2.5% as
anticipated inside the huge support tube
is the hadron kilometer which stops the
heart runs and measures the energy and
inside that in turn is this huge array
of BGO crystals shown here one half
finished one half still being loaded
with crystals into the carbon fiber
structure these crystals for the first
time
were grown in equality and length so
that the electromagnetic showers could
be recorded with 1% accuracy above 2 GV
was done in China the performance can
best seen from PI zero to gamma gamma
decays which is resolved to seven MeV
the Sigma to Lambda gamma with four MeV
and the ETA which just was addressed
with 16 MeV in 1990 the Machine started
in 98 in 1990 130,000 said zeros got
collected which gave rise to 35
publications in 1991 another 300,000
said zeros got recorded so the total is
almost half a million now which gives
rise to enough determination of precise
parameters of the standard model and
measures lifetimes very accurately
all in all 60 papers let me address just
a few of them we need as a matter of
fact very accurate luminosity
measurement to do precision measurements
which is done from small angle Bhabha
scattering you can see that the
measurements as points and theory agree
is very well so that we can say the no
Manasa T is known presently to 0.6% and
will be even better in the future with
that we can measure as a function of
energy of the Machine the hydronic
events and obtain a line shape of a
bright Wigner here which if magnified is
incredibly accurate
this shows the differential of the
values if you look at events which have
strong energy deposits back to back in
the bgo crystals it's a plus e minus and
you can plot those they also follow a
line shape of the set zero after the T
channel contributions are removed if you
look for back-to-back neurons in the
immune system here again you can observe
the line shape and the peak of this
distribution gives you the partial width
down here you see Taos decaying into an
electron the other one into three pylons
which would enable you to measure the
lifetime which was done they also follow
the same line shape so that we have now
very accurate results of this partial
widths from electrons muons and Tau's
down here hydronic width is measured
here the width of the set zero is fitted
and a very accurate measurement of the
mass has been done now we can ask what
is missing and the missing channels if
you attribute them to neutrinos you find
there are three neutrino species in this
world unless they are heavier than 45
GeV so dark matter has to be searched
elsewhere one also can measure with
electrons muons and Tau's
the leptons the forward backward
asymmetry that an electron scatters
forward or backward their symmetry is
shown here as a function of energy going
through the set zero mass the reason
this is important is because this
asymmetry if you calculate it from the
vector and axial vector coupling
constants it expresses itself in this
term and you can extract it from this
measurement and the partial width
measurement we are just shown they are
elected related to the standard model
coupling constant with the Weinberg
angle
the result of this is shown here
GG VGA on a very enlarged scale G a is
close to the expected value of minus 0.5
this are the 1 Sigma 2 Sigma contours
and from this we can evaluate the sine
square theta effective and from
refinement of the calculation of the
partial widths we can conclude that the
top mass must be around 196 GV let me
come to a test of QED from a plus a
minus goes to gamma gamma which has
nothing to do with the set 0 in fact the
gammas are strongly peaked towards the
beam line and very well described by QED
with cutoff parameters which are very
high and let you conclude that electron
radius is less equal to 10 to the minus
18 meters also if you consider gammas
from the east or exchange this there is
no room for it and the mass must be
bigger than 122 GeV if it exists let me
switch from QED to QCD which was now
calculated completely to second order
looking at three jet events and looking
at smallest energy jet scale to the beam
energy we see a strongly falling
distribution which happens to agree to
the QCD calculation for a gluon spin one
if the gluon spin was zero this
distribution wouldn't fit at all in QCD
we should have flavor independence of
the coupling constant it shouldn't
depend on which kind of quark you use we
can single out the heaviest quirks known
now be quirks by large PT muons and
measure for those events alpha s and it
turns out to be the same than for all
the others which is a necessary
condition
the thrust distribution which is the
project of energies on an axis is known
over four decades now and agrees with a
theory very well this allows to extract
as coupling constant and the value you
find this way is point one one eight
however if you use other methods you can
get higher results therefore we give an
average of 0.125 and consider at
theoretical uncertainty of 0.08 search
for the standard Higgs it's done
by looking for set zeros decaying into
Higgs and the virtual set zero which in
turn decays into neutral between anti
neutrino quark anti quark leptin anti
leptin this is a process which is
completely calculated so if the Higgs
mass were 40 GeV you should find so many
of this kind of decays and of neutrino
decays so this is the prediction for the
various channels none no such event was
seen therefore one can say up to the
three 95% confidence level that the
higgs mass must be bigger than 52 points
3 GV there is an event which is bigger
than 50 2.3 GeV and which fulfills the
topology which we expect from such an
event in that it has a mu plus mu minus
and 2 rather broad Jets which could be
attributed to a BB bar and they would
form a mass of about 70 gav but clearly
a likelihood of such a thing occurring
is low and it needs more events charge
takes was searched for in the towel
channels and cs bar the result is that
up to 45 GV nothing was found
the following things are unique to the
l3 detector and its features the ETA was
always a little mysterious as it was
mentioned before it can be observed with
the bgo with very good resolution and
high certainty the spectrum of it as
observed in set zero decays however as a
function of the relative energy follows
exactly to what you expect and therefore
is nothing mysterious three gammas can
be detected very well and said zeros
should not decay into it unless there is
a signature for new physics one event of
this type was seen 0.5 are expected from
QED that lets us set a branching ratio
of 10 to the minus 5 for this process
not to happen cut photons we'll explore
the details of the interaction at short
distances if you compare the 0 to K into
QQ bar with a gluon emission the color
string lines will lead to the gluon if
you have a QQ bar where the gamma
emitted the color line goes from the
core to the court so you expect more
hydronic to energy to be ejected in this
part here and this is an energy flow
diagram and the purple line gives you
this process and indeed there is more
hydronic energy ejected for this gamma
events than for gluon events and in the
other half it's the other way around as
it should be so this gives insight into
the color string structure effects
physics of heavy quarks
they can be singled out by muons having
a high transverse momentum with respect
to the general jet axis of the order of
a quarter of the mass that lets us
select very well be mesons from other
things because a cut at one-and-a-half
GeV and Pt leaves you only with this red
stuff which is prompt B decays that's
true for muons as well for electrons
taking only those events with a high PT
moon you can again plot their occurrence
and they follow a bright Wigner shape
again of the set zero with a partial
widths of eight three hundred 85 MeV as
expected we extrapolate the muon that he
came you and towards the beam will since
it's a decay miss the exact beam point
by impact parameter Delta evaluating
that gives you a measure for the
lifetime which is 1.3 Pico seconds from
this lifetime and knowing the branching
ratio on how often BS decatur leptons
together with low-energy data from Clio
we can evaluate the transition matrix
element from bees to cease to be 0.04 6
looking into big z0 decays with new
plasma minuses the invariant mass peaks
at 3.1 GeV showing the J resonance and
the branching ratio for this process is
four times ten to the minus three re
extrapolating and mu plus mu minus two
the decay point gives us a measure of
the decay time by this distance this is
a different method which agrees exactly
to the first one in giving one point
three picoseconds taking this be events
and looking by the charge of the muon
for the forward backward asymmetry we
find one which is 0.08 which would allow
to extract the coupling constants for B
maslin's B mesons can mix first normally
if we have a beam S on it will decay
only an mu minus and the e minus not mu
plus email us the b0 bar however will
decay into mu plus E Plus but what may
happen with the probability chi of
mixing is that this B turns into a b0
bar in that case it ought to decay into
mu plus as well as the other one so like
sine die leptons indicate that mixing
took place just counting the events of
normal occurrence plus/minus
combinations and those which have equal
sign and therefore could be due to
mixing lets us determine the mixing
parameter to be 11%
leptin flavor violation in C zero SDKs
would signify themselves by said decane
to say a mu plus tau minus or vice versa
in that case if one looks for muons only
one should see muons which peek at beam
energy and due to the good muon
resolution they should be within this
red indicated diagram as you can see
you're only see decay muons from tau
events and therefore we can set upper
limit of 10 to the minus 5 for this
process not to happen tau polarization
recording 2 plus 2 minus events the
towers are polarized between helicity
minus 1 and helicity plus 1 States the
measurement of the polarization is
important because it determines the vine
back angle directly the measured
spectrum of tau is decaying into a pies
and caves is given by these points here
the analytic helicity once amplitudes
had shown down here and minus 1 here
they together explain the data and
measure the polarization
so from tau 2 pi decays the polarization
is minus 15% but you can do it also from
tau te and tau 2 mu decays and with this
following results averaged to minus 13
percent polarization other topic is a
model independent analysis of the number
of neutrinos which relies on the
following effect although you create a
c0 which decays in neutrino neutrino bar
it may have emitted a gamma beforehand
and that gives you a big major that this
process took place the spectrum of this
gammas is given by this blue histogram
in calculation and agrees exactly with
the data if the number of neutrinos is 3
so this gives an independent
confirmation this is a very interesting
event we have two of which was a hard
muon 2 had neurons and two hard gammas
which are not close to them what is
surprising about these two events
measured with the extremely good gamma
gamma resolution the invariant gamma
gamma mass for both of them is close to
60 GeV and then there is nothing before
you have here QED QED
Corrections a long distance away let me
summarize major results from l3 based on
1/2 million set 0 events number of
neutrinos is 3 lepton radius measured to
be smaller than 10 to the minus 17
centimeters and quarks as well mass of
Higgs must be bigger than 53 GeV the m0
mass is known to a very high accuracy so
is the partial electronic widths the
properties of heavy quirks have been
measured there
precisely the decay times of B mesons
the mixing of B mesons has been
determined and a precise determination
of the strong coupling constant to
second order has been achieved unique to
l3 other results that the B to C
transition matrix element was measured
in four different methods the sinus of
the Tedder wine back angle was
determined an independent confirmation
that the number of light neutrinos is
indeed three was given flavor violation
and set decays does not take place the
flavor independence of QCD is manifested
by bees
the ATAR spectrum does not show any
anomalies the unexpected decays like
this indeed don't exist the heart photon
emission from quarks agrees
very well with expectations and confirms
that also quarks are very point like the
branching ratio into J particles was
measured as four times ten to the minus
three and a mass limit for excited
electrons set to over 120 2gv
what will be next six million set zero
events which allowed to search for new
phenomenon as the last mysterious events
I showed you precision tests of the
electroweak theory in 1970 94 the energy
will raise to two hundred GeV or above
and enable W plus W minus protection
with this luminosity in three years to
test electroweak theory is further make
a hick search up two masses of 80 to 90
GeV and search for new phenomena the W
plus W minus production is interesting
and that it can proceed with the
following three diagrams of which this
one is specific to the non abelian
nature of the standard model together
they give the very mentally
cross-section shown here
if this graph wouldn't exist they would
raise to very high values this is even
demonstrated more in the angular
distribution which the de camión from
this double use would have with respect
to the beam axis cosine here in the
standard model you expected very steeply
rising angular distribution whereas if
this graph doesn't exist it would be
very much flatter and you see many more
events in the backward hemisphere after
all these successes with the standard
model let me say remind you that the
standard model has 20 undetermined
parameters which have to be taken from
experiment namely the coupling constant
lepton masters and the quark masters and
emitting parameters and 13 of those come
from the so-called hick sector which has
to be explored in future and that I will
leave Gregg hurtin because if you plot
this masses on a strongly logarithmic
scale you see that they are all raising
upwards and something ought to happen in
this region thank you
you